do you ever look around and think back I
know you've been so many years after
you've grown but do you ever look back
and think to that young Pat who is
looking for answers trying to struggle
you know I know in our prior interview
you had talked about some of the earlier
stuff when you were living in LA and
trying to you know figure things out
make ends meet going to the gym and
really trying to like get things
together do you ever trip out do you
ever like pinch yourself holy how
did how did this all happen when I was
just that young man looking for answers
yeah you know it's it's crazy when
you're saying this because we're having
a conversation at the house the other
day that you tripping out holy
there's there's no question about it
there's no question about it and a lot
of times it's more when I'm talking to
my kids late at night and I'm like you
know like I was saying for my Sunday
they said do you realize if if I don't
come to the states and my parents don't
bring us to America you're not here
because I'm glad your parents process
I said do you realize if I don't go into
that meeting
that night I don't meet your mom do you
realize if this and I kind of go through
this right do you realize if that day we
didn't make a decision on September 23rd
3 30 in the morning I wake up in 09 and
I tell my wife I'm resigning today I'm
starting a company and I'm gonna go
through God knows how many years of just
challenges I said you guys are not going
to be here today so so that part of it
is a beautiful thing the concept of
where I was at to where I'm at I've
always been a dreamer never in a million
years
did the 18 year old Pat think this was
going to happen I went into the army
thinking I'm going to do 20 years
meaning at 18 years old when I went to
the US Army I'm a Hummer mechanic I'm at
Fort Campbell Kentucky I get every
single order I requested from lieutenant
colonel colonel peacocks I'm gonna stay
in I'm gonna do my 20 years they went to
Virginia they got my orders to go to DLI
I speak four languages so they were
going to send me to Monterey to learn
different languages I was going to go to
Vicenza Italy I was going to Sears
School Airborne Special Forces 18 Delta
fifth group I got every single order I
wanted until I got a call one day from
one of my friends
who call me in the middle tonight 12
o'clock and he challenged me to get out
and the next day I woke up went to my
Colonel and I said I'm getting out and
then boom everything changed so what if
I stay six more years if I stay six more
years in the Army then I'm in it for
eight and a half years I only have 11
and a half more years to retire with 50
retirement benefits am I Really Gonna
Leave the Army if I re-enlist that day
I'm getting out of the army six years
ago at 38 years old probably been
married three times I probably got seven
or eight kids and I'm probably broke
with eighteen thousand dollars in the
bank and maybe I'm not even getting yeah
maybe I have to stay another five or ten
years to get my 100 pensional retirement
you would have no clue who I am so the
life is literally this close we were
having a conversation right now with one
of our guys who got a fat bonus and he
got a fat raise and the bonus I put for
him in 2023 is literally looking at me
with a smile on his face saying holy
I want to make a lot of money this
year I said do you remember the
conversation we had
uh nine months about the sushi spot he
says I do I said do you remember what I
told you so of course I remember what
you told me I said what I told you is to
follow and I said to you how many more
times are you gonna take new challenges
and the moment it gets hard you're going
to run away from it how many more times
I said Einstein said genius is when you
stay with problems longer why do you not
stay with problems longer until you
solve it why do you not do that to
yourself I say your biggest enemy is
every time there's a new problem you you
fly you run away you cop out you do this
stay with this damn thing for five more
months see what happens stay with it for
six more months stay with it for another
year stay with them for two more years
and then see what takes place with it
and then all of a sudden your best
friend momentum shows up and then now
you're overpaid now you're overly famous
now you're overly getting credit
for what you're not really doing but
what you did a year and a half ago two
and a half years ago so that concept of
staying with problems longer uh is what
sometimes we don't give enough credit to
but life to me is a is a combination if
you have a big life or a bad life
It's a combination of five major
decisions that you'll be in that moment
and I'm convinced one day when you die
and you're in heaven or you're 80 years
old on your deathbed and you're by
yourself you're gonna go through those
five decisions uh one is could be
marriage you should have married that
girl or you did and it was a good thing
or you did it wasn't a good thing so I
knew the signals why did I I knew the
signals why didn't I it could be drugs
it could be arrested could be an
opportunity it could be Investments it
could be bad habits it could be bad
friends you're going to go to those five
moments you're going to say man I'm so
glad I made that decision because of
that I have this or man I missed out on
that so you know none of us can predict
fully the future but it's going to come
down to those five decisions did did it
feel guided for you like were there
times where you struggle because I know
a lot of people especially in social
media age and you know we probably have
a pulse you know kind of being in our
20s early 30s it's a lot different a
time than than you guys were maybe
people stayed a little bit longer with
stuff and I love that you mentioned that
you stayed you know you made the
decision to stay in 20 years but there's
a lot of people now on social media who
are in an opportunity in this shiny
object syndrome on social media someone
says do this someone says do that
for you did it feel guided did you go
I don't know should I do this
should I do that or did it did it feel
like you always kind of knew where to go
or were there late nights where you go
I don't know if I should leave
military to do this I don't was there a
lot of I don't know asking people for
why 100 and and kind of spinning in
circles or pushing about it yeah there's
no question about it I'll give you an
idea so one day uh it's me and the the
valley Total Fitness produce a lot of
killers great sales people I'm telling
you right now uh one them is in our
office but it produced a lot of great
sales people right and in in the LA area
there was a few guys that you knew they
were gonna do something it was myself it
was another guy named Tariq it was
another guy named Dan a few other guys
but those are the main names I'm talking
about right so we all were competing
we're all 21 years old around that age
is where we are so we're sizing each
other up to see what's going to happen
but we all know we're not going to do
ballets for the rest of our life we just
don't know where people are going to go
so one day
so everybody leaves a couple of them
going to Real Estate couple them going
to loans couple them going to all these
different business everybody goes in
what year are we talking this is 1999
this is 1999 99 2000. so I'm sitting
there I'm like okay I I can't go into
real estate and Loans because
everybody's going I'm gonna go and you
know what I want to do I want to go to
being a stock broker so I go to 911. I
go to Morgan Stanley dinner a day before
9 11. Monday Tuesdays 9 11 9 10 is my
first time like oh bad timing right
I go to Morgan Stanley Dean with her and
I'm sizing everything up I look at
insurance I look at annuities I look at
401K I look at hedge fund I look at
mutual funds I look at stocks I look at
real estate I look at I look at all this
stuff and I said okay I know I'm gonna
be in finance I just don't know what
part of Finance I'm going to be in I'm
not going to be doing all of it I got to
pick one of them
so I chose Insurance the other guys they
chose loans one day I'm at B of A this
is two years later so it's all four
something like that
I might be of a and I'm in line
talking to the teller arguing over
329.95 uh what do you call it over limit
fee or over whatever over over traffic
and I'm like this is this sir we can't
do nothing about it and I'm like upset
at this lady and then I look to my left
and it's one of the other weekend
managers
I said hey what's up dude I'm like I
hope he didn't hear but he heard what I
was saying is how you doing Paris
everything's good everything's good
evening good very competitive because
because everybody was like who's getting
the hot girl who's going to Garden of
Eden who's showing up with the hottest
girls who's doing this it was so
competitive
everybody's competitive and everybody is
somebody especially in L.A yeah and and
and it was uh these were like the main
core guys that we were very competitive
and I hear okay great good senior Pat
yeah I'd like to make a deposit of a
half a million dollars
I'm looking at him I'm like this motherf
yeah yes I have a million dollars oh Mr
this his last name I'm Patrick but he's
Mr something yeah yeah annoy the hell
out of me and you're a little draft
dealing with 329 over so I'm like holy
moly so I go
you know when you're broke and you leave
a restaurant and you have dinner with
somebody you're trying to impress them
or sell them something this is the rule
of thumb always remember this when
people are walking out if somebody says
you have to go to the bathroom what
great seeing you they have a bad car the
other guy's a nice car sure the person
that has a nice car is is very
comfortable leaving with you at the same
time to call the valets and guards so I
was the guy that was out good seeing you
I'm gonna use the bathroom and then I
would wait outside okay he's gone all
right can you get my Ford Focus and then
I'm leaving right
so I go outside the bank and I'm just
sitting there in the car seeing what it
does what does he pull up with he pulls
up with a nice you know whatever was at
the time a Lambo or a Porsche or Ferrari
and he leaves him like this guy man I
know I'm better than this guy so then
everybody says why don't you go do loans
why don't you go to Real Estate why
don't you go do this you should do that
look what they're doing look what
they're doing and I'm this close
to leave an insurance to go to loans
this close now here's what happened with
21 inch 25-ish 26 ish so one day I go to
this one guy who's a realtor every time
I tell these stories my realtor friends
love me because I I you know talk a lot
of to them but this this and by the
way there's a lot of money to be made in
real estate I bought this property I put
barely God knows how much money down
payment six months later I got an offer
that gave us 400 return on this because
they're building 300 units here so there
is money in this it's just not my game
right real estate quick sidebar how much
have you spent on real estate since the
acquisition not a lot 20 million to 35
million 35 million 30 chump change for
Patrick David not a lot but it's not a
lot if you think about it's really not a
lot about 35 million
um but uh uh so you know I'm I'm looking
at this guy saying he's going to go do
this but I'm coming back and I'm sitting
there saying what industries am I going
to get involved in so I'm having dinner
with the scan Valencia one time 60 year
old man his pictures everywhere as a
realtor
Saturday night we're having dinner great
guy telling stories making good food
beautiful view in his backyard it's nine
o'clock he says all right man I gotta go
to sleep
I said you got to go to sleep or what so
you've been a real estate how long 35
years he says I got to go to sleep why I
got a show on 8 am in the morning
I see you got to show an 8 am in the
morning he says yeah I'm a realtor
I said there's no way in the world I
want to be a realtor I'm not doing that
I don't want to give up my Sunday now
that's me yeah you want to show time
noon I'm not going to be a realtor then
I looked at the mortgage side look
what's going on right now with real
estate every five to ten years in the
mortgage industry you're going to have
rates that are going to go up so if you
make three years of a million dollars
and you make three years of 150 000 you
didn't make a million dollars you made
3.45 million dollars over a six year
period so three point five four five
divided by six years is what 550 000 per
year but you lived a life of a million
dollar you're income for three years now
your real average is 550 and most people
when they live a life of 1 million they
don't save thinking they're going to be
at 550. boom lose the house boom sell
that pet Tech watch for 200 000 that you
paid 500 000 for sell the other house
sell to sell that and then boom back at
it again hey the next run and the next
round I'm like what do you have left and
big Banks don't buy mortgage companies
because the X Factor on the ebitda is
very low because it's all based on that
personality there is no renewals there
is no residual there is no Equity so you
can make a lot of money as a loan office
or a lot of money 100 200 half a million
dollars a month you can make a lot of
money in real estate if you're properly
investing it on the side and you're
getting rental a lot of guys are doing
that they're killing it more power to
them but most guys in real estate and
Loans don't do that so I sat there and I
said 20 years I'm going to give one
thing which one is it going to be and
then I solved for what I'm going to be
building with insurance because
Insurance wasn't a sexy industry not
everybody looked at the insurance
everybody thinks real estate is sexy
mortgage is sexy stocks are sexy who the
hell thinks Insurance sexy perfect I'm
gonna go in that space and if I become a
leader in that space guess what there's
a lot of value for me I have a lot of
Leverage I can make a lot of ass I can
push the weight a little bit I can push
the envelope a little bit so that's the
part where I almost went into real
estate and loans and not doing it is
because sometimes not enough people
think 10 to 20 years so I it was this
close for me to have left the insurance
industry to real estate alone and that
was one of those key five decisions
there's no question about was it was it
something that you kind of struggled
with for over a period of months weeks
or was it like once you made the
decision you were done or did it tempt
you over the time because I'm sure you
had hard times with insurance it wasn't
like you started it you were on a rocket
show so I'm driving we're having lunch
today with my wife we're coming back on
baby I love this car here's what my wife
says she says yeah babe you're gonna get
bored in three months I know you and I
said what do you mean she said babe
that's your personality that's why you
can't keep cars for too long I've never
heard you love a car that you want to
keep it I'm like listen to him like you
know what she's right the crazy part is
I get bored very very quickly where I
want a new challenge right so I know
that area of mine but I'm also a guy
that likes routine I'm also a guy that
likes to sit in the same corner at the
same table order the same three items
have the same waiter I I want that to me
is also so control the controllable
control the controllables but also
understand the temptation of many
options many opportunities especially
when you become very good at what you do
you know other people who are like four
levels above you again be like man
you're doing greater than insurance but
if you were only a stock broker you're
doing great in this but let me tell if
you were you're doing great on but if
you were doing solar we would be making
a meal you're doing you're like oh you
think I'll do good in solar or you'll
think I do good in this and it's so
tempting but you can't be naive because
every business you go into is hard every
business you're going to his heart there
is no such thing as one industry it's
easier than the other one and all that
other stuff there's not you just have to
know long term what you're solving for
so the Temptation is going to be there
you have to be aware of yourself are you
the guy that doesn't stay with problems
long are you the guy that falls for the
Temptation and the flattery of oh my
gosh you're so amazing
I've never met somebody as eloquent as
you would do good so good selling our
products you would be so good doing this
and you're like oh my God this is a
great feeling this is fantastic but that
means for the rest of your life flatter
is going to control you and if you're
controlled by flattery let me tell you
you don't control your life people
control you through flattery and it's a
it's a flaw that many of us
it takes us decades to learn that we all
have because we like it you can't fall
for it but flattery ruins a lot of
people's lives
yeah
foreign
[Music]